hello again from South by Southwest I'm
here today with Stan Greene the director
of the Masters of entertainment industry
management program through the Heinz
college hi dan how are you how are you
thanks so much for taking the time to
talk with us today tomorrow we are going
to be talking with the students from
your program but since we've been
following them all weekend I wanted to
talk to you first a little bit about the
background of the program so can you
tell us a little bit about the program
itself and then about coming to South by
Southwest every year absolutely so we
just celebrate our 10th anniversary of
graduating class of Los Angeles last May
of 2016 as of right now we bout it we
have about 180 alumni around the world
from our program it was interesting
again Martin the Dean of the College of
Fine Arts actually founded the program
with the thinking that people are always
worried about how are you making a film
and who's acting the film but is anyone
thinking about the business aspects of
it and a lot of times the folks who were
making those decisions did not yet
either have the management skills or
perhaps they were lawyers and they
didn't care as much perhaps about the
artistic part so we're trying to marry
both the creative aspects as well as the
management aspects of a program and
that's why it's founded in two different
colleges it sits in both the Heinz
College of Public Policy and management
as well as the College of Fine Arts and
our students are really delving from
both sides we have students with
backgrounds in acting and directing in
film production but we also have a lot
of students with a background in
economics business and even everyone
thought we had engineering students as
well the idea behind the festival's
actually started with Sundance we were
in the third year of the program we knew
that film development and film
acquisitions was an important aspect we
had a class in film acquisitions but I
believe as much as you talk about film
acquisitions really being at a festival
and seeing what's happening and watching
the business deals that's really what's
most important so in this particular
case we said let's go to Sundance and we
did and it was a great success that we
enjoyed it a lot and the students
learn so much by being at Ground Zero
and the following year we wanted to
replicate Sundance once again but we
said we really should do something for
the first year students since the second
your students go to Sundance and that's
where we spoke to a lot of our faculty
who are go to all the festivals and many
of them said you got to go to South by
Southwest its unique festival that
marries both film and television as well
as the interactive and music and we
certainly haven't regretted it since
we've been going here since the fourth
year of the program yeah that's great um
and there is so much happening at South
by Southwest but you also brought in
specific speakers for the students
yesterday and Saturday tell us a little
bit about that sure so both when we
started this we wanted to there's so
much noise going on at South by there's
a lot of great seminars but all of those
seminars are really focused for the
masses so in any particular barroom you
might have 100 200 people but we want to
make something special just for our
students so what we do is we produce a
series of breakfast seminar so I call it
meim at breakfast at South by Southwest
and people will come in this year I
think we've had a stellar group of
individuals we had Michael wam be from
the social edge of the past Fox and
Nielsen executive to talk about research
which i think is really important with
pablo gonzalez who's the CEO of tug
which is a film exhibition company
really amazing he calls himself a
technology company but it's really about
film exhibition we had amber gear lost
in you and I spoke earlier today who's
doing social media for good and is a
snap top 50 synopsis synopsis women of
the year so she came and spoke we had
people from both CBS acquisitions as
well as Focus Features talking about the
nitty-gritty of acquisitions and and it
sounds so sexy and cool and it is cool
but their schedules are crazy they start
seeing films at ten in the morning and
they go till two in the morning and they
see eight films a day sometimes so
they're really really busy and then we
kept it all off with Ruth Vitali who is
the CEO of creative future which is
really working with the motion picture
association of america to try to combat
piracy
doing a great job and she brought with
her Richard gladstein who is nominated
for two Academy Awards and his produce
films like Neverland and pulp fiction
and reservoir dogs and on and on really
special terrific guy that's so cool um
like I said we're going to be talking to
the students tomorrow but for people
watching right now who might you know be
hearing what you're saying and be
excited about the program what type of
student are you looking for well so you
were specifically a master's program so
we're looking for folks of a bachelor's
degree who number one I know it sounds a
little cliche but they got to have a
passion for the Arts there's certainly
easier ways to make a living but being
in the entertainment industry has so
many rewards so we're something looking
for people with that passion and
background as I mentioned earlier
they're quite varied but we do look for
people who have somewhat of an
entrepreneur spirit and who are willing
to kind of take off and really go at it
now we don't teach classes in producing
its interests me we teach many crimes on
producing we don't teach them in film
cinematographer anything like that but
many of our alumni have actually gone on
to make films or produce films and
similar so it's really that marriage of
right brain left brain and that marriage
of creative as well as the business
analytics because their students end up
in so many different places as well as
agents and management that's another big
area so sometimes people come in and say
I love the entertainment history I don't
want to be the talent but I want to
negotiate the deals for the talent and
that's a great area for us as well well
thank you so much enjoy their time here
have a great time here so I have yeah
we've been covering all sorts of stuff
and we have a lot more that we're going
to be covering so be sure to watch us on
Facebook snapchat Twitter Instagram
hashtag CMU at SXSW thanks so much Jen
course bye-bye
you